All right. Good afternoon. Why don't we
go ahead and get started? It is 12:30.
I want to thank everybody for making time out of their day, especially a
beautiful day like this, to come and attend this session.
My name is Sam Blackman. I'm a pediatric oncologist, a neuro-oncologist, and
currently an entrepreneur in residence at Google Ventures.
I'm very pleased to lead
this session entitled "El Camino de la Pediatria: Finding Our Way
Through the Chasm of Pediatric Oncology Drug Development." The goals of this
session really are to evaluate where we are in what
has been, I think, a long journey since the pediatric
rule of 2008 really spurred
industry to do more work in pediatric development.
In those past 17 or 18 years, we've
certainly had some advances, and we've had our fair share of
frustrations. And in talking to my colleagues,
Ted Leach and Beth Fox, we felt that this would be a good time for us to
evaluate where we are,
celebrate the progress that we've made, and at the same time, highlight where the
stumbling blocks still remain.
I have the following disclosures here that I won't go through in any great detail.
So when we picked El Camino, I thought everybody's going to immediately
think about this, or at least people of a certain age are going to think about
this, because that's really what most people in the United States think about when
they hear El Camino. But we are not going to be talking about this
incredibly precocious sport utility vehicle.
No, we're going to be talking about this El Camino, which is
El Camino de Santiago. And for those of you who are not familiar with
the Camino de Santiago,
it is
known as the Way of St. James, and it's a network of ancient pilgrim
routes that stretch across Europe,
mostly through Spain, and they all converge at the Cathedral of
Santiago de Compostela in Galicia, Spain, or if you're Spanish,
Galicia.
Traditionally, it's a Catholic pilgrimage.
It was started over 1,000 years ago and intended for pilgrims to
visit the burial site of St. James.
The thing that's really interesting about the Camino is that there is no one single
path. There are many different routes, and some
are quite long, including the French route of 800 kilometers.
And the duration really depends on the pilgrim.
The full journey can take over a month.
Many pilgrims choose to walk smaller sections in one to two weeks.
What's really interesting is the arduousness of this journey.
And when I sat and thought about the journey that we take in pediatric cancer
drug development, I thought about the Camino, I realized that there are some
remarkable parallels there. The Camino is a long, arduous
journey with multiple paths and a low full success rate, and there
are, of course, data to back this up.
Based on statistics provided by the Pilgrim's Office in Spain for 2024 and
2025, the percentage of pilgrims who complete what's traditionally considered
the full Camino
is approximately 6% to 8%. And for those of you who've spent
time in drug development, that should sound familiar, because
the likelihood of getting a drug from preclinical all
the way through approval and commercialization is about
6% to 8%. So
I thought that these parallels were
striking enough that it warranted naming this session and really
contextualizing this session around this idea
of the Camino, of this very long pilgrimage.
Pediatric cancer drug development is a journey, and an extraordinary one
at that, but it's also an extraordinary challenge.
Many start, we put many, many drugs into the clinic, and few
finish. And by finish, I mean getting across the line of regulatory approval and
commercialization. The need for this pilgrimage has
existed for many years before us, and we will need it for many years to
come. And for those of you who've taken long treks,
walking these types of treks is an opportunity for deep contemplation.
You think about where you are, where you're going, and how you're going to get
there. And my hope is that through this session, we will all be able to take some
time to contemplate where we are, where we're going, and what we need to do to
reach that goal of developing new medicines for children with cancer.
So your guides for this pilgrimage today are Ted Leach,
Associate Professor of Pediatrics at Children's Hospital of Philadelphia and an
expert in precision oncology, who's going to be talking about precision
immunotherapy.
Beth Fox, who is a Senior Vice President for Clinical Research at St.
Jude, and again, an extraordinarily accomplished
pediatric oncologist, is going to be talking about small molecules and ADCs.
And I will be talking about bridging the gap between science and market access.
So with that, let us begin. I'm very pleased to welcome
Beth up to the stage.
Well, thanks, Sam, and thanks everyone for coming.
This is really an interesting opportunity to step back and ask
ourselves where do we want to be on this journey.
And so this is my disclosure slide.
I have no financial conflicts of interest.
These are the formal objectives for the program, but I wanted to frame them in the
context of the theme that Dr. Blackman has laid out for us.
The starting point, where we're at now. I'll show you a few slides about that.
I want to talk about the journey in the context of how we think
about adult-driven dependencies in our clinical drug development,
and I'll use examples from antibody drug conjugates.
Then to think about the horizon, I'll use examples of novel small
molecules to really look at my perspectives on
the impact and interplay between regulatory approval,
adult indications, and practice-changing trials.
And finally, the destination. We know where we want to
be. We're not there
yet.So these two graphs show
the FDA approval of oncology drugs for children and adolescents
over time. And as Sam described, really through
incentives and hard work, we have seen an
exponential growth recently in FDA approvals for drugs.
The blue line are the cumulative approval of the agents.
The green line is the indications.
In the bottom bar graph, it's really a snapshot of the last 10 years,
where the vast majority of this
progress has been made, and it is real progress.
When you look at the last three years, we are consistently having
drugs approved for children with cancer.
Let's step back and look at new drugs approved by the
FDA, oncology products in last year.
This is set up as a table where we're going to look at this targeted small
molecules, antibodies, antibody drug conjugates.
Some combinations were actually approved, and one cytotoxic,
treosulfan. When you look at it, it's divided by adults
only indications, those indications that are
indicated for use for children 12 and older, and then all means
that the approval includes the youngest children.
Not unexpected, targeted small molecules in adults are
a major area for new drug approvals, and we see the growing
approval of antibody drug conjugates, especially first in
class.
The important thing that we think about
is the all approvals, down to the youngest
of children, and I will talk toward the end of this
presentation about the importance of Dordivaprone and how we got there.
But we can't look past Mirdametinib and as a MEK inhibitor, its
approval.
So to hone down a little bit more, I looked at 2025
FDA approvals in children. Small molecules, three of them.
The Belzutifan is a hypoxia-inducible factor inhibitor,
encabozantinib, a multi-tyrosine kinase inhibitor.
Both of those had their labels expanded to include children
greater than 12 years of age with neuroendocrine tumors.
Importantly, selumetinib had a label
expansion to go all the way down to children one year and older,
and all the way up through adults with plexiform
neurofibromas. The development of selumetinib, as many of you know,
started with orphan drug designation and breakthrough treatment
designation, and its first approval was actually in children greater
than two years of age back in 2020.
In terms of antibodies, nivolumab and ipilimumab have been approved and a
label expansion for their combination use in children as young as
12 with MSI high colorectal cancer.
So let's widen the lens a little bit and look at a World Health Organization
analysis that was published in 2023 of 440 therapies.
And what these two pie graphs do is compare European Medicines Agency's
authorizations by age group with FDA.
And as you can see, for both, the vast majority of drugs are
used as off-label and unapproved.
Importantly, for children only approvals,
there were only two in the European Medicines
Agency and five by the FDA.
So this is our starting point. We've seen exponential progress.
It's real progress,
but it's not enough.
We know that the annual FDA approval rate of eight to nine agents
includes 10 to 14 new indications or expanded labels.
And what we saw in 2025 was one
drug actually approved for all age groups and four in
adolescents.
Overall, there are fewer drugs authorized by the EMA than the
FDA, and that is not news. And I do think that changes
in European clinical trials regulations that are coming in the coming
years will probably begin to address that
inequity. And between 2019 and
2023,
when you look at all oncology drug approvals, the most
highest number occurred in China, followed by the US,
then the EU, and then Japan. So this is a good start,
but how can we accelerate, and where do we really want to be?
So this is a landscape analysis done using
clinicaltrials.gov exploration earlier this month and
curated. What it shows is that for antibody drug
conjugates, there were 712 trials registered
worldwide. Two hundred and twenty-four of them were treatment trials that
were actively recruiting, and they're color-coded here for adults,
adults and child, and child only.
The size of the bubble indicates about the approximate number of trials.
And as you can see, there
are more trials active for solid tumors than there are heme malignancies.
But right now, in April, there are really only
a few trials that include children, and they're all in the heme malignancies, as
outlined here.
And they include important trials like the GLOBE BNHL
platform trial for CD19-directed
ADC in NHL, and the
MyChild01 for AML with a
CD33-directed ADC, and another trial in children less than
18 years of age of CD22s.
When we look at the solid tumor, I could find no actively accruing
trials for children or people under 18.
It doesn't mean they're not out there. It means they're not accruing.
But there are a number of really important targets, and I'll talk about some of
them todaySo this looks at the
milestones for ADCs in children. And we'll use the example, which is
a highly successful example, but it's also highly emblematic
of traditional drug development.
Brentuximab vedotin for classical Hodgkin's
disease, it's an anti-CD30 monoclonal antibody,
ADC, and it was initially developed by Seattle Genetics with
a phase one trial in adults. Their pivotal trial was a phase two
trial in relapse and refractory
classical Hodgkin's
lymphoma, and that led to the first approval.
It was after that first approval that the first phase one trial was sponsored by
Seattle Genetics in children, and later the phase three trial
was conducted in the cooperative group setting.
I think what we know now is this was back in 2011,
2012, and now with the Race for Children Act,
the gap between that pivotal phase two and the phase one, two
trial in children is highly likely shortened.
But what we have to concentrate on now is getting the trials open and
completed and demonstrating activity in children faster.
Challenges in drug development for ADCs are many.
This is one example. The folate receptor alpha is
expressed on the cell surface of some common adult cancers, including
ovarian, lung, and breast cancers.
The clinical development in adults is primarily focused on ovarian
cancer. This, however, is also expressed
on a very rare, highly aggressive pediatric leukemia that
occurs exclusively in children who are less than
five. And this highly refractory to conventional
chemotherapy, high relapse rates, and poor overall survival for these
children make this one of the most unmet needs in
pediatric specific drug development
endeavors that you could think about.
So there were nine trials of
folate receptor alpha in ADCs that were open,
and
eight of them were in adults, one of them was in children.
But the interest in doing this in children actually started with expanded
access experience, which was published for
leveltumab or SUTRO-002, which has a
tubulin payload. This treated 10 children with
monotherapy. Their median age was as we'd expect for this disease
at two, and three of these 10 children in the monotherapy only
arm
had complete responses. In addition, this experience showed
us that we could combine this with other chemotherapy, and we could
also use this as a bridge to transplant for these children.
This led to the launch of the pediatric specific clinical trial,
and this clinical trial went through a lot of reviews to be
ready for the FDA to position this drug to move forward in children.
However, it was activated in December of 2024 and closed eight months later.
This really demonstrates that the commitment to pediatric drug
development has to include prioritization by drug companies.
There are other folate receptor alpha ADCs out there.
There are also CAR T cells, and when you think about
ADCs and CAR T cells, CAR T cells will be academically
driven, but what's the endpoint? And I think that's a critical question we have to
ask ourselves.
So what's on the horizon for ADCs? This is, we all know
inotuzumab,
and its intended toxicities of hepatotoxicity and
myelosuppression. AstraZeneca has a new
CD2 directed ADC that has a topoisomerase one
inhibitor as a payload, and they're doing the phase one study in adults.
The toxicity is to be determined, but the hope is that by changing the payload
and some features of the antibody itself, we can decrease that
hepatotoxicity for children.
This looks at the milestone developments of trastuzumab
deruxtecan. This is a HER2 directed
ADC with a topoisomerase payload.
The pivot preclinical testing program looked at this agent in a
variety of solid tumors, and this is a graph of the mRNA
expression. It was paired with immunohistochemistry cell
surface expression. And what's circled here is osteosarcoma.
This drove a dose confirmation and phase two
trial of this agent in patients with relapse and refractory
osteosarcoma.
And what we learned in the development of that trial was being developed
in the time when we were trying to understand how much expression of
HER2 was necessary for activity. But this was actually
complicated by the fact that we had to use a very different antibody
to screen osteosarcoma. And we ultimately screened
50 participants who were all greater than 12 years of age, and the vast
majority of them, as shown in the bar graph, actually had expression.
We enrolled nine patients to the first phase of a
two-stage phase two and saw one
dose limiting toxicity and one patient had prolonged stable disease.
That did not meet the bar to move forward
to the second stage. And as you can see in the bar graph, it was a patient with
relatively low HER2 expression that had this long-term stable
disease.
But coincident with this, we went back to the pivot data and said,
"What about Wilms tumor? Should we do a cohort of patients with Wilms tumor?" And
in fact, we are amending this trial to do just that.
In addition, Dr. Slotkin at Memorial Sloan Kettering was
using an off-label experience in a series of patients with desmoplastic
small round cell tumor, and she presented this at ASCO with really
dramatic responses. So this group of patients will also be added to the
trial, which we hope to activate in the coming months.
So what's on the horizon? We're not going to look too far into this, but STEAP2 is
a very interesting transmembrane epithelial antigen of prostate two
metalloreductase. It facilitates endothelium mesenchymal
transition. It's on cancer associated fibroblasts, a
number of adult malignancies, and notably important
areas of high unmet need in pediatric
oncology.In addition, there are a number of clinical trials in
development for ADCs directed at B7-H3 in the
pediatric domain, and we look forward to being able to
launch those in the near future.
So I wanted to put this up as we transition into solid tumors, and it's
really to make the point that we all have a role to
play in this journey. And this is the story of
larotrectinib. So the first trial was the
landmark trial that received age and histology-agnostic FDA
approval and ultimately EMA authorization, and truly met
the bar that Dr. Blackman described as a
critical landmark in the destination regulatory
approval. But what I'm here to tell you was that was just the first step.
We had a drug that we could use, a dose that was safe, a
formulation that mattered, and was appropriate for children.
The pediatric oncology group conducted the NCI-COG pediatric
match, a huge platform study that included larotrectinib and
evaluated patients with relapsed and refractory
NTRK1, 2, or 3 fusion-positive solid tumors,
and really demonstrated the proof of principle that you could do a biomarker
selected trial group wide with more than 200
institutions, and a really important step forward. But Dr.
Leitch, who we'll speak to in a little while, actually did the pivotal trial that
tells us how to use larotrectinib.
What it is, it was in patients who had newly diagnosed
NTRK fusion-positive tumors, and we used
larotrectinib neoadjuvently, so prior to surgery.
And we were able to follow the patients not only for their response in a
newly diagnosed patient, and in this case with infantile fibrosarcoma,
but also understand that could we reduce the morbidity of
the surgery that those patients would do and what happens after
surgery. Do you restart, do you not restart?
Those are the practice-changing questions that this academic trial
answered.
So when we look at hematologic malignancies, what are the challenges?
I'll use the example of venetoclax, the BH3 mimetic that
selectively inhibited BCL2. These are three
trials that were done in children after the FDA approval of
venetoclax and azacitidine or low-dose cytarabine for
older adults with AML. The first trial really
demonstrated that we could safely administer venetoclax in combination with
cytarabine and idarubicin, and demonstrated an activity
signal that was impressive. The second trial is a trial that was done in
China of 65 children that were accrued in a one-year period of
time and showed that in newly diagnosed patients, they could
achieve complete remission and MRD negativity at high
rates, and the event-free survival overall looked good.
The third trial is actually an ongoing trial we don't have results for yet, but
this is being run through the PEDAL initiative with
ITCC and is a randomized phase three that uses standard
chemotherapy with or without venetoclax in patients with
relapsed or refractory AML. The point of this slide is to say
all of these trials are great and amazing.
Venetoclax is commercially available, and almost every child with AML is
getting it off label right now. So how do we move forward to
understand how to use it in the upfront setting and what its true effects are?
And perhaps we're going to look to other newer BCL2 inhibitors to
answer those questions directly.
So, another milestone, and an important milestone, is
the FDA approval of dordivaprone, a first in class
agent that antagonizes the dopamine receptor D2.
It also activates mitochondrial proteases and
results in an integrated stress response.
One of the highest areas of unmet need in all of pediatric oncology
is diffuse midline glioma, and it is
characterized by these epigenetic dysregulation and impaired cellular
stress response. The regulatory pathway for
ONC201 was a long one. The first orphan designation was
achieved in 2016 and the rare disease designation
in 2020.
It is right now, as of August, the first systemic therapy approved
for progressive diffuse midline glioma, and the approval includes
patients
as long as they're greater than one year of age.
And this approval was achieved through a pooled
analysis of clinical trials that showed overall a
22% response rate. This is from the academic
publication that
gives you a lens on what went into the drug approval
package, but is not the entire drug approval package.
It started with 376 patients, and those were
all used in the regulatory approval.
But the academic publication focuses on 50 patients, and the
waterfall plot is seen here with the very dramatic
improvement for those patients.
So the lessons along the way.
There are alternative routes to getting where we want to go.
We showed you a little bit about off label and how does that contribute not only to
clinical trials and launching clinical trials, but what does it mean for the
regulatory approval? Pooled clinical trial data is common
for FDA
submissions and approvals, but what does it mean to pool it across that
small number of patients and that many trials over the period of time?
And finally, expanded access, making sure our patients have access to really
important drugs, and how do we incorporate that data into
more rapidly getting to a clinical trial?
Drug development is dependent on adult cancers, and this is fueled
by commercialization. And we have to live with the reality that the
market share for all pediatric cancer is not large enough to
really contribute to this fuel.
We can all be dis-dissatisfied with the pace
of progress, but the pace of progress has been real.
We're undaunted. We will continue this journey.
And finally, my personal opinion is this journey is well worth
it. Every patient is well worth it, and we must continue.
So the destination. This is where the real questions are. Where are we going?
We've tried a lot of things to get there.
There's lots of different routes to get there, but we have to take opportunities to
travel together. And by that, what I mean, the example of the
development of the antibody to do the IHC
screening for HER2 is a really important
example. We need to insist that the
biomarkers are relevant to pediatric cases from the very beginning
of development in adults.
Developing therapies for pediatric cancer specific
indications, of course, this is what we all want to do, and there are unique
pediatric cancer cell surface antigens that may not have
ADCs developed for them, and we may be relying purely
on the academic trials of CAR T cells for those cell surface
antigens. But really what I'd like you to think about is looking beyond the
approval to the access and cures.
Different groups may excel at different segments of this journey, the
commercialization piece, the practice-changing trials, and
ultimately improving outcomes for every child everywhere.
We have to cooperate for comprehensive development pathways from the
beginning and have commitments that we are committed to moving
further and faster and explore alternative pathways for development
of new therapies in which we can partner in a more seamless way.
So with that, many thanks.
The
talk is open for questions if you have questions at either microphone.
So maybe I'll start. So Beth, the example of
Sutro O2, which I think is a really important example,
raised a question in my mind, particularly as you talked about alternative pathways
to development and trying to think outside of the box.
And correct me if I'm wrong, the reason that trial was
terminated early was because the company essentially ran out of
money,
and was no longer able to sustain development.
In that instance, in the absence of a sponsor who's got the
resources to move that drug forward, but I think in the instance of
O2, there was clinical supply.
Are alternative paths, could you, as opposed to moving a drug forward
and paying for expensive registrational trials to move it towards development, just
keep a trial open given the small number of patients until a
next generation folate receptor alpha therapy comes forward?
Is that a viable alternative to bridging the gap, if
you will, until we have a definitive therapy that can be commercially developed?
Yes. And it is something we
all want to make happen, and in fact, for this particular drug
and this particular company, we tried.
A number of people tried through partnerships that really were
alternative, meaning could we put a bridge together for
a way that the children who benefit and need this could have access to
it, and we could continue to generate data, not
necessarily toward a commercialization and FDA approval
for that particular ADC, but I see it exactly as I see
all expanded access experiences.
We need to generate data faster. We need to use those
as bridges to clinical trials, but importantly,
we can't take three years to develop a clinical trial.
We have to get more efficient and get those trials
open because the most important thing I think we have as academic
pediatric oncologists is the ability to generate the data
faster because that's what matters.
And it's harder to say no to data than it is to say no to the absence
of data.
Dr. Janeway.
Hi, Beth. Very nice talk.
My question for you is could you comment on
sort of the wisdom of lumping together diseases that
are small people pediatric diseases like rhabdomyosarcoma, Wilms,
neuroblastoma, and diseases that are big people pediatric
oncology diseases, as you know, my greatest interest, osteosarcoma,
Ewing sarcoma, but we could think of synovial like that, for example.
Is it good to put them all in the same pediatric drug development bucket, or
is there some path forward where we think about these two things as sort of
separate?
I think it's an important question, Katie, because
we can drop the age on trials all we want, but can
we accrue
between 12 and 18 at the sites where it's open?
The other challenges that come in when
if we were to build an all comers, all age group trial are,
as you know, the ways that we develop the participant
criteria are very different in children and adults, and having the
patients upfront to invest in that and actually
build the extra expense of doing that and the probable
extra effort of the monitoring and so forth to treat little people,
that's going to take a commitment on whoever planned the
adult trial. But I think those are the conversations we have to have.
It also doesn't align super well with the
medical system, particularly in the United States, where adults oncology
is over there and pediatric oncology is over there.
I think there are some great institutions like yours that have better
bridges between those two things, but we really need to foster those.
Thank you. I guess I would say without the concept of adolescent
drug development for pediatric cancers, we'reGoing to always
lump, and I'm not sure that always helps the big people, pediatric cancer
patients.
Yeah. I was actually shocked when I did the landscape analysis of ADCs
about how few of them dropped the age.
Yeah. I think it's not about dropping the age.
I think it's about having adolescent trials, like intentionally bridge
pediatric and medical oncology from the beginning.
Mm-hmm.
Dr. Lawler.
Thanks, Beth.
So I have a philosophical question that sort of stems from your landscape analysis,
where with all those solid tumors, no ADCs for kids.
But if you did the same analysis with CAR T-
Mm-hmm
... for many of the same targets, you would've seen an abundance of trials.
So
is this just a bias in the pediatric field that we're comfortable
with T cells? What are your thoughts on that?
What's the path forward for ADCs with that landscape?
So, Ted may be touching on this in his talk, but
I think
my perspective on it is because CAR T cell
studies are academically driven by pediatric
oncologists, we define our unmet need.
We see the cell surface, we say, "There can be a CAR for that," and we
drive those trials. For ADCs, it's a very different
environment, where it sort of gets to Katie's question, is
who's setting up the first trials and how are we thinking about it, and are we
thinking comprehensively about the different targets?
Thanks.
Thank you, Beth. Appreciate it.
And now, following
Dr. Fox is going to be Dr. Ted Laich from Children's Hospital Philadelphia.
Thank you, Sam, and thank you, Beth, and Dr. Lawler for the nice segue.
Yes, I'm happy to talk about precision immunotherapy, and I'm going to talk
about primarily CAR T cells, because as you heard, that's mostly what we do in
pediatric patients, but also a little bit about bispecific antibodies for childhood
cancer.
Here are my disclosures, and I didn't write it here, but as you will see in a
couple slides, almost everything I'm going to talk about is not approved for
children because almost none of these drugs are approved for children.
So again, back to the roadmap and the Camino.
So I will start off by talking about where are we now, and then talk
more about the journey to get here.
And really, it's been an exciting decade, where we've seen really
practice-changing impacts of FDA-approved CAR T cells and
bispecific antibodies for the treatment, primarily of pediatric
B-cell acute lymphoblastic leukemia, which most of you know is the most common
pediatric cancer. And I would argue that while I've certainly been involved
with the development of some of the therapies that Dr.
Fox mentioned, I think this has had the greatest impact on pediatric
oncology of any of the therapies we'll talk about today with
curing more children with B-ALL. Then I'll talk some about
novel CAR T cells that are under study and bispecifics, and that may impact
pediatric cancer, and some of the challenges to get those to
the finish line,
as described by Dr. Blackman. And then discuss, I think, whether or not the
goal is FDA approval of these therapies or whether
ongoing academic clinical trials or compassion access programs are the right
mechanism to benefit patients.
And so as was suggested, this is a similar analysis to what you just
saw from Dr. Fox, this time focusing on CAR T cells for
both solid tumors and hematologic malignancies, again, pulled from
clinicaltrials.gov. And what you can see here
is that certainly hematologic malignancies have had the greatest number of CAR
T cell clinical trials,
but that there are a large number of clinical trials for
both pediatric patients and adults,
in both solid tumors and hematologic malignancies.
And in this case, many of the peds plus adults trials are actually pediatric
trials where we've extended the age range up.
So these are pediatric trials where the age range goes to 25 because we want to
capture the young adult patients, rather than the reverse that you heard about from
Dr. Janeway, where it's an adult trial that may extend the age down to
12, but often has few children who enroll.
And in total, there's more than 2,000 trials that have been
activated over the last decade,
and more than 100 of these are for children.
So here you can see the timeline, and the top graph is showing the
number of trials activated each year for adults
in red and orange, and then children in blue and green for
hematologic and solid tumors respectively.
And as you can see, there's really been this exponential increase in the number of
clinical trials.
But that has not followed with an exponential increase in the number of FDA
approvals. So pediatric patients, many of you know,
led the way and pediatric approval of
tisagenlecleucel was actually the first FDA approval of a CAR T cell
therapy for the treatment of cancer back in 2017.
But since then, there have been no additional approvals of CAR T cells for
pediatric cancer.
And there have been eight approvals of adult therapies or indications of adult
CAR T cell therapies.
So I want to talk about what we've seen over the last decade with
these bispecifics and CAR T cells for pediatric B-ALL, which is
really where they've had the most profound impact.
So the first agent that was really studied was blinatumomab, which is a
bispecific CD19/CD3 antibody,
that
there was a published phase 1/2 clinical trial in patients with relapsed and
refractory ALL, where we first saw the promise of this type of therapies with
27 of 70 patients achieving a complete response.
These are patients who historically have a very low response rate to
therapies in the multiply relapsed and refractory setting, and nearly all of
these patients would die of their disease before this therapy was
developed.And so again, as you saw in the last model,
this initial data, which was
conducted with an industry partner, was translated to the academic setting,
through the cooperative group setting, and the COG ALL 1331
trial was a randomized Phase 3 trial that evaluated
blinatumomab in patients with first relapse of B-ALL.
And what you can see here is that there was numerically superior
disease-free survival and overall survival with a p-value
of 0.9 or 0.11 for each of those in these
patients, and also less toxicity, which is very important
in this trial,
in the blinatumomab arm. So really practice-changing results showing that
this therapy can be integrated earlier in treatment.
And then again, following the model you just heard from Dr.
Fox, this was then studied in the frontline setting because, of course, our
goal is to prevent relapse to begin with, rather than to have second and third and
fourth-line therapies. And so the ALL 1731
Phase 3 trial enrolled 1,400 patients with standard risk
B-cell ALL and added two blocks of blinatumomab therapy,
and just was reported a couple of years ago that this resulted
in a 96% disease-free survival in these patients.
So 19 out of 20 patients were cured with this therapy,
which was better than the still quite good 88% disease-free
survival for patients treated with chemotherapy alone, and FDA approval
was expanded to include frontline treatment, and this has now become the standard
of care for children with B-cell ALL across the United States.
And in fact, we've learned that this may actually alter the way we risk stratify
patients. So on 1731, patients
who were
average risk, which is not the most favorable group, achieved disease-free
survival that was comparable to the most favorable group in the
historical outcomes. And so it may be that we can actually change how we think
about risk stratification and downstage some patients now that we
have these newer therapies. There's also the potential when you see
excellent outcomes like this to think about can we eliminate chemotherapy or at
least eliminate some of the chemotherapy for these patients to allow
decreased toxicity for our patients?
And I think that's certainly a consideration that the ALL group
is thinking about today.
So changing your attention now from blinatumomab, a bispecific antibody,
to CAR T-cells and tisagenlecleucel, which is to
date still the only FDA-approved CAR T-cell for pediatric cancer.
As I mentioned, this was approved in 2017 for patients with relapsed and
refractory B-ALL based on a trial that enrolled
79 patients
and was a highly refractory group of patients with a median of
74% blasts in their bone marrow and three prior lines of
therapy. This was a single-arm trial because these patients had
historically very poor outcomes, and 81% of patients
achieved remission.
Essentially all of these were complete responses or complete response with
incomplete count recovery. And here you can see the overall survival
of this group is just above
60% at three years, which is really quite remarkable for this group of
patients that historically were expected to have a 20% or
worse survival.
Ongoing studies have evaluated the use of tisagenlecleucel in the real world
following approval, and again, we see very similar results,
85% complete response in both the CIBMTR and the
Pediatric Real-World CART Consortium data sets with close to
200 and 250 patients in those two data sets.
And again, about half of patients appear to be able to maintain
durable remissions after CAR T-cell therapy in this highly
refractory group of patients. And we've actually seen that the toxicity has been
less in this group because of
use earlier in therapy when patients have less disease burden.
So these have really, again, transformed the landscape where blinatumomab is now
standard of care for patients with newly diagnosed B-cell ALL,
and CAR T-cells are certainly standard of care for patients with relapsed and
refractory B-ALL.
But moving forward, I think I want to highlight some of the exciting therapies
that we've seen, but then also talk about the challenges and why none of these are
actively moving towards regulatory approval at the moment.
So we know that not all patients will achieve durable remissions
with first-generation immunotherapy, and these can
be both to loss of functional CAR T-cells as well as antigen escape.
And there have been trials adjusting this, trying to use humanized CAR
T-cells to address the potential
immunogenic rejection of the murine construct.
And some of these have demonstrated very good outcomes.
So a trial I'm highlighting here demonstrated a 98%
objective response rate in patients who were CAR naive and
64% in patients who had previously progressed
after CAR T-cells. And this trial suggested these patients may
have more durable persistence. But despite this,
this remains an academic trial and not something that's moving towards
commercial development.
We also know that some patients lose expression of the CD19 antigen on their
leukemia as a mechanism of resistance, and there have now
been multiple trials of CD22-targeted CAR T-cells
for the treatment of B-ALL, which have also demonstrated high response rates
in a number of different institutional trials at the NCI, at Stanford, and at CHOP,
all demonstrating 70% to 75% objective response rates using
CD22 CAR.
Although these responses are less durable than the first generation CAR T-cells,
it suggested that perhaps we could use a combination strategy to
prevent resistance, and this has now been explored in a number of other
trials where again, we see high response rates, 86% to
99% in clinical trials of patients with
CD19, CD22 dual targeting CAR. Some of which
report very excellent long-term outcomes, including
a 73% event-free survival in a trial of almost 200 patients
reported from China.So really exciting results, but again,
not currently being explored or not FDA-approved for
pediatric patients.
And then turning your attention from leukemia, where these therapies have really
had the greatest impact, to solid tumors, I'm going to highlight sort of some
of the works in progress here, and I do think this is a work in progress.
We have certainly seen some activity of CAR T cells in patients with solid tumors,
but it has also certainly not been the level of activity that we've seen in
patients with leukemia.
So I think the best results that have been published to date for a pediatric
solid tumor CAR T cell trial
came from this trial from Italy, where they conducted a trial
of a third generation CAR, which was a GD2-directed
CAR, and reported a 66% objective response rate
in patients with relapse or refractory neuroblastoma,
and higher activity in those with low disease burden and fewer lines of
therapy, and with some patients reporting durable survival, as you can see in
these curves. So certainly, a potentially promising
therapy for this challenging group of patients
that deserves further study.
There's also been some interesting work in using GD2-directed CARs for diffuse
midline glioma. This is a phase 1 trial
that
was conducted with a second generation CAR, where they reported three out of four
patients had a radiographic response in these
H3K27 mutated diffuse midline gliomas, although the
responses were relatively short-lived, with all of the patients passing away
from disease within a year of treatment.
And to address this, they have followed this up with
a trial using armored CAR, where
you use an IL-7 receptor to try to increase
persistence of the CAR, and reported that seven out of eight
patients had at least stable disease,
and some neurologic improvement that lasted an average of five months.
There's been a number of other
studies trying to further improve efficacy of CAR T cells
for pediatric solid tumors.
This, that I'm highlighting here, is a trial of IL-15 armored
GPC3 CAR T cells that's expressed on a number of different
tumors, including hepatocellular carcinoma, which is a
pediatric and adult cancer, but also hepatoblastoma, a cancer
that occurs in very young children.
Again, expressing IL-15 to try to promote CAR T cell expansion,
and reporting that with the combination of these two, they saw
responses in 33%, four out of 12 patients.
But these were, again, relatively short-lived.
So I think what I'm trying to highlight here is that there are some exciting
results in solid tumor CARs, but they're also certainly not of the same
magnitude that we've seen in the leukemia space to date.
And so, certainly deserve further work and
preclinical and clinical investigation to figure out if this is a
path forward for this group of patients.
As I highlighted, there's a number of different of these CAR T cells under
development. This is not an exhaustive list, but just a number of trials that are
ongoing at multiple institutions of different CARs against different
targets for leukemia, including B and T cell
ALL, as well as AML, for a variety of solid tumors,
and for brain tumors. And so I think it's really been an exciting time where
there's been a lot of these clinical trials.
But with a few exceptions, and there are exceptions, most of these are
academic studies conducted at a single institution.
And so it does pose questions as to how we're going to
move this forward in the future.
So,
with the last few minutes, I'd like to talk about the destination and
is FDA approval the goal? Certainly, that has been expressed as the
goal for small molecules, and if it is the goal, why have approvals been so
limited in this space?
And I think the underlying problem is what you've
heard throughout, is that there's limited investment in
these trials because they are
expensive and have a small market.
And I would argue that we don't necessarily need FDA
approval of these therapies in the same way that we do of small
molecules or other biologics, because
uniquely, CAR T cells can be manufactured in the academic setting, and
that's essentially unique to all of the other types of therapies that we're talking
about, whether antibody drug conjugates, bispecific antibodies, or small molecules.
All of those essentially will require a manufacturer.
In this case, individual institutions can manufacture this at
relatively reasonable costs of about $50,000 per patient
manufacturing cost, which is significantly less actually than the costs
that we are charged for commercial CAR T cells.
I think there are certainly challenges with this approach, though, right?
So I highlighted some exciting results from GD2 CAR T cell trials,
but there's been a large range of these trials, and the results are very variable,
and there's differences in the constructs, there's differences in the manufacturing
process. And so if we have individual academic centers
each manufacturing their own product, how do we ensure that those are consistent
and functional, and that the patients are getting the best therapy for their
disease,
when we don't have comparative trials, and we don't have
the consistency that's achieved with FDA approval and a standard
manufacturing process? And I think, of course, I've focused
primarily on the United States, but this is even more challenging to scale
globally,
where many centers may lack the resources to deploy these
therapies for their patients.
And I would, again, say that I spoke most about CAR T cells today, but I
think lack of FDA approval is a more challenging problem for bispecific
antibodies that are generally not going to be manufactured in the academic setting.
And so these generally follow the paradigm that you heard from Dr.
Fox earlier about needing to expand what's being
done for adult patients to
pediatrics.I'd also
like to just talk for a minute about, um, repurposing adult
therapies within this space, which I think is somewhat more challenging than you
think about for small molecules. Um, if you look back to Dr.
Fox's talk, a number of the agents that were approved are small molecules
that have received histology agnostic indications based on a genomic
biomarker. Um, so that's certainly true for the ertrectinib that she mentioned.
Also, some of the immunotherapies, um, uh, like the anti-PD-1
therapies, um, have all received histology agnostic indications that included
children and then could be done in a relatively small pediatric patient
population, not having to focus on a specific histology.
But I think that's harder in these, uh, therapies that are based on expression
rather than based on genomic biomarkers.
Um, some of these therapies do not have a formal companion
diagnostic like blinatumomab or tisagenlecleucel, although institutions
routinely assess CD19 expression by flow
cytometry, but others do. So afamelcel, which is a
T-cell receptor therapy, um, that's approved for patients with synovial
sarcoma, requires positive immunohistochemistry for
MAYJ4. Um, but these assays are typically only validated in the disease
of interest, in this case, synovial sarcoma, um, and have not been, uh,
studied, um, in across, uh, histologies. And as Dr.
Fox mentioned with the trastuzumab example, it can be really hard
to move these antibodies across different therapies in a way that are not
true when you're using a sequencing-based assay looking for a genomic fusion
or a point mutation, which generally can be applied regardless of
histology.
We certainly can think about other methods like RNA-seq, but, um, these don't
assess the actual expression or translation of the protein and are
not typically what's being validated for, um, the companion diagnostic
for these therapies in adults.
And I just highlight a couple of examples where this is, um,
being studied. Um, so this is a pediatric trial of
afamelcel, which as I mentioned, is a T-cell receptor, uh, therapy against
MAYJ4, um, that demonstrated a forty-three percent response rate
in adults with synovial sarcoma, um, and is now being
studied in the pediatric population.
Um, this trial was initially accruing children with a number of different diseases
and now has been restricted to patients just with synovial sarcoma,
um, uh, to just evaluate that patient population, so
limiting the number of pediatric patients who will be included.
And then I would just highlight one other, um, example, um, where there
were some more challenges, which is, um, tarlatamab, which is a
DLL3/CD3 bispecific antibody, um, that has, um,
had a significant impact in the treatment of adults with small cell lung cancer,
um, where in a randomized trial, it demonstrated a higher response rate as well
as improvements in progression-free survival and overall survival.
Um, DLL3 is expressed in neuroblastoma.
There was a paper published several years ago, uh, demonstrating that in a
subset of neuroblastomas, DLL3 is expressed and that a
DLL3, um, antibody drug conjugate was active in preclinical
models. Um, but tarlatamab was not studied in children.
It was, um,
at the time on the FDA-relevant target list, and so it was granted a
waiver. That waiver has since been removed, but the drug has now been approved,
and so there's no longer a requirement to study the specific drug in pediatric
patients that may apply to future drugs.
And I just highlight, this is actually one of my patients where, um,
that this drug may be applicable to pediatric patients.
This is a patient of mine who had a chemotherapy refractory high-grade
neuroendocrine tumor, um, who received this therapy, um, off-label and
has an ongoing metabolic complete response.
So some of these, uh, rare therapies do need to be studied in children, and we need
to think about how do we assess expression of these targets in children, um, more
broadly and across histologies to make sure that, um, these therapies
can move to our pediatric patients.
Um, so with that, uh, I hope I've talked a little bit about, um, my perspective on
lessons learned of a decade of bispecific and CAR therapies, um, for children
with cancer and really highlighted the sort of revolutionary, uh,
impact of blinatumomab and tisagenlecleucel for children with B-ALL,
and how we've seen, um, promise of other CAR T-cells primarily
in hematologic malignancies, but also in solid tumors.
But very limited, um, commercial development in this space, uh,
despite the substantial academic interest and number of trials that are being
conducted. Um, and highlight a little bit the potential to
leverage products primarily developed for adults, but the need to think about
how do we systematically assess these targets in pediatric
cancer in a way that we, I would argue, have not yet done.
Um,
we've done this for genomic targets, but not necessarily for all these
expression-based targets in pediatric cancer.
Uh, again, thank you very much for your attention, and thank you again for the
invitation to speak.
This, uh, talk is certainly open to questions, uh, at either microphone.
So, you know, I was struck and have thought,
I think a lot of people have thought, Ted, about, you know,
the point that you brought up that maybe we don't need to have CAR T-cells
approved. Maybe this can be more like transplant where, you know, these, uh,
products can be generated at institutional level, administered at institutional
level. But it raises, I think, you know, an intriguing set of
questions because,
you know, allo transplant is to some extent allo transplant, and you can get it
pretty much anywhere in the United States.
But if it's only CHOP that has,
you know, some future DLL3 CAR T-cell, uh,
and others don't, then that makes it very difficult,
uh, for patients, you know, who are not in
the catchment area of Children's Hospital of Philadelphia to access
that therapy. There's also, of course, the fact that you can scale
CAR T-cells, um, but it is a lot of work and it still does cost a lot of
money. So I'd love to hear just your thoughts on, you know, imagine a world
if we, you know-took this idea to
its logical conclusion. And then also how is it, for example,
at CHOP, that you're sustaining that infrastructure?
Could CHOP be a CAR T-cell factory, but for the
Philadelphia area? And is the funding for
that
going to be sustainable? Are you able to have the institutional commitment to make
those products available for years to come?
I know you're not speaking on behalf of CHOP.
Yeah. Thank you for the question. Yeah, I certainly can't speak on behalf of
CHOP about what we can sustain. But I think that is
the question. I think that's the key question, and I think there's two issues, one
of which is what you mentioned in terms of geographic access, that if some therapy
is only available at the East Coast or the West Coast or in the middle of the
country, it's a significant burden on patients and families to travel, and
not everyone will have the resources to do that.
And then that will limit access to patients of certain
sociodemographic
characteristics, which will not be good.
So I think that is an absolute challenge.
I think the other challenge is, even if there are multiple individual academic
centers that are doing this, which there are now.
There's CAR T-cells at CHOP, but there's CAR T-cells at St.
Jude, there's CAR T-cells in Seattle, there's CAR T-cells in
Colorado. And if we have those
studies, but they're individual studies of an in single institution, it's very
hard to know if the same therapy is being given at each of those places.
Because it's not just even the construct.
We know that there's manufacturing differences, and the cytokines that are used to
stimulate the cells, and the growth conditions all can impact the ultimate
efficacy of this therapy, which is different than transplant, right?
Pretty much if you have an auto transplant, we can standardize
most of the key areas across institutions, and I don't think
we've solved that problem yet. There have been some early efforts to do
multi-institutional academic CAR T-cell trials, but those are still quite early.
And I think it is a challenge. I think individual institutions are
sustaining this through a variety of different mechanisms, including
philanthropy, including clinical revenue from the associated
care that goes along with treating patients, which
often requires significant hospitalization and/or
ICU care. But I don't think we've solved that problem yet, and I think that's
really the problem to be solved.
Dr. Kearn.
I'm here to defend the FDA, which it must be snowing in hell right
now.
Remember, the FDA is not just to approve drugs so that companies can
charge. They perform critical functions to ensure that the
quality of the data, reproducibility of the data, that the
tracking of toxicities, many of which, particularly in a long-term
pediatric population you may not know for many years, performs some
critical functions that I don't think we ought to ignore.
And to me, it's not so much a question of can we figure out a way
around the FDA. It seems like what we need to do is help the FDA
come up with mechanisms that are not always dependent on the
large, expensive pharmaceutical trials if academic
centers can generate this. And for those of you that have been part of the
accelerate platform stuff, as you know, there are
certain things that we can add to pediatric trials
that would allow the data to become registrational or at
least guided towards registration without having to reinvent the whole
trial that can be done academically.
And so I just want to make sure that we don't lose what are some of the
true positive components of the FDA.
Excellent point.
I'll just add real quickly that I totally agree, and I certainly don't mean to
throw the FDA under the bus. I totally recognize those
functions, and I think that's what I was highlighting a little bit in my response
to the last question, is some of the challenges if we just do academic trials
without that goal. I think you're right, though, that the challenge is if it's
a billion dollars to get FDA approval,
no institution is going to be able to afford a registrational trial of
their institutional CAR T-cell.
We can take one more brief question. Dr. Janeway.
Sure. I was going to provide,
actually, not in the CAR T-cell, but in the ADC example, the DLL3, kind of
the opposing question, which is, for an example like that,
something like a pragmatic trial that requires minimal data collection that
just allows you to get enough data to have it added to sort of disease
guidelines so it can be paid for by insurance is, to me, the solution
there. What are your thoughts about that and how we can do more of those types of
studies?
Yeah, no. I agree that I think that
we have a long history in pediatric oncology of practicing with off-label
therapies.
And it wasn't until, as Dr. Fox highlighted, recently that we started to see
approval of things for children
more commonly.
So I think that's certainly possible.
I think that's more possible in the AYA
space, and that is in the young disease space, because you can
probably infer dosing and safety in a 14-year-old
post-pubertal female to an adult, but you cannot necessarily do that in
a two-year-old
small child. And so, there's formulation issues, there's
safety issues, there's dosing issues.
So I think that is definitely true in those older patient populations.
Thank you.
And I would just add, I think the two questions are
well-placed, right? Because
pragmatic trials
are great,
but
what Mark was talking about is the FDA is going to look
for certain things for approval. That's
important, the safety. And we have to be somewhere in the middle,
because if we put something that looks closer to a pragmatic trial
through a review process and everybody wants to add all the pieces to it,
we're never going to get out of the review process, let alone to the trial
activation.
I was talking about the pragmatic trial and foregoing FDA approval and
justdoing what we need to, to get insurance companies to pay for it
and for us to know what we're doing with it, right?
Because what happens now is we just use an off-label like here and there and
write a case report, and that,
to me, doesn't tell you what you need to know. How long do you treat for?
What can you expect from this therapy?
What's the duration of activity? That sort of thing.
Yeah.
I will.
Thank you, Dr. Leach, and hope to maybe address one of your points there, Dr.
Janeway, in this next talk.
So I'm going to wrap up by
continuing the
El Camino metaphor and then layering on a
little Martin Luther King there and talk about going from the mountaintop to the
promised land.
I really feel like in all of this with the
Catholic pilgrimage overtones and the current political climate, I should have had
a little Pope Leo pop up here on my screen at some point to endorse this talk.
But I want to talk from
both a drug developer and now venture capitalist perspective on what it
takes to make novel therapies a reality for
childhood cancer. And again, my disclosures here, and I will talk a little bit
about approved and unapproved agents, but I think probably the bottom part is the
most important for me because I do work for Google.
It's important for me to say that I am not here representing them.
I'm here of my own free will and volition.
So to carry over the theme, I hope to talk a little bit about where we
are now in terms of the business side of the business.
What have we learned from the past 15 years of trying to accelerate the development
of new drugs for childhood cancer?
And in this very tumultuous environment, how we can adjust and adapt to this very
rapidly shifting scientific, financial, and regulatory landscape.
Because
to think that the status quo is going to be the status quo in a few years, I
think, is mistaken, and
many changes are afoot that are moving at a furious pace
that are disorienting, I think, even to the most seasoned biotech
and biopharmaceutical professionals, let alone folks in academia, and we need to
anticipate those changes. And then I want to talk a little bit about the
destination, because I've been on both sides, both in academia and now in
industry and on the investor side, all three sides.
And I like to think that I have maybe a little bit more holistic view and
can begin to see where we're working together well and where we're working at cross
purposes. And I think at the end of the day, we all need to continue to ask
ourselves, how do we ensure that our efforts are coordinated
towards the goal of pediatric cancer medicine development, which I want to
distinguish from drug development.
I would be remiss, again, in a talk where you're making an allusion to a
pilgrimage that started 1,000 years ago, to at least not
recognize the fact that nearly everything that we're discussing this week at AACR
actually started with pediatric oncology.
And I think it's important to remember that we really were the
alpha for the field of cancer therapy.
Of course, this is a figure from the seminal paper from Sidney Farber in "The New
England Journal of Medicine" in 1948, showing the first patient, a child put
into remission with aminopterin.
And for many pediatric indications, as we've seen, it
feels like we've reached the mountaintop in terms of our ability to
do things scientifically, but we are having a hard time reaching the promised
land of having drugs that are approved at the same pace that we do for
adults
and making them widely available.
So I want to talk a little bit about where we are today, because I
think it's really important to recognize that we
are in a period of great abundance, which far outstrips our
resources to leverage that abundance.
And that's a theme that's going to run through this discussion.
We are continuing to experience a sustained,
now in its second decade, revolution in cancer drug development that looks very
different even today as it did compared to five years ago.
If you look at this data from the IQVIA Institute, and this is a remarkable report
that they put out every year, and it's all publicly available, and I would
encourage you to read it to get a sense of the landscape of oncology and broader
drug development.
Even if you look at the past five years on the graph on the list, you can see that
the proportion of drugs that are being brought
forward in new oncology clinical trials has shifted
dramatically away from the immunotherapies that dominated the middle part
of the 2010s and the small molecule kinase inhibitors that dominated the
early part of the 2000s to therapies that we didn't even imagine
would be possible 15, 20 years ago.
Cell and gene therapies, multi-specific antibodies, antibody drug conjugates
representing nearly a third of clinical trial starts for solid tumors.
And you can see that also represents about 43% of clinical trial starts for
hematologic cancers. So we are in the process of
a remarkable shift in the landscape, and this will only continue.
The innovation cycle in biopharmaceutical development is really just beginning, and
I think those of you who have spent time wandering the various sessions here and
are seeing this next generation of molecular glues and even more specific
or mutation-specific or pan mutation-specific small molecule inhibitors, in
addition to the plethora of multifunctional ADCs, you know that there's
certainly more to come.
What's really interesting about this is that most of this innovation is
not coming from large pharmaceutical companies.
And I think that that's an important statement to make because we talk about pharma
as if it's a monolithic entity of just these big companies with billions and
billions of dollars in their pocket. That is not the case.
60% of clinical trial starts are coming from small,
emerging biotech companies. That's EBP, emerging biopharmaceutical
companies. These may be pre-commercial companies that aren't generating
revenue but have investment capital and a finite amount of investment capital with
which they need to do their work. And not only are these emerging biopharmaceutical
companies responsible for now the majority of Phase 1 clinical trial starts, they
are responsible for the majority of Phase 2 and an increasing number of Phase 3
clinical trial starts. What does that mean?
It means we are shifting the expensive part of drug development onto
companies that have a finite amount of capital and are not raising any
revenue, which means when the money's gone, the money's gone, and if they don't
have additional data to raise more money, then the company is done.
And I think that that's very important because these companies have different
priority structures and levels of
resourcing.And it has
been a rough five years for the biopharmaceutical
industry. And when I gave a
version of this talk a year ago, I only had the figure on the left-hand side, which
was a headline from Stat from February 2025.
It was really a dark, dark place. And the metric
that's being shown here is the XBI, which is an index of
biotech stocks compared to the S&P 500, which is the standard
stock market index you're all familiar with, looking back over the past five
years. And you can see that if you're just looking at return on investment
in financial markets, five years of biotech innovation resulted in
zero financial returns relative to the S&P 500.
And now fast-forward not even a year and
a half, only about 14 months, and it really feels like the party has started up
again. And we're seeing, of course, a surge.
The XBI is now well above 120. We're seeing
IPOs start to happen and large Series A and Series B financing
rounds start to happen again. So we are finally recovering,
but this interruption in capital flowing into biotech companies has had some
interesting knock-on effects that I'll talk about in a minute.
So a number of things have happened that have made this
both dip in biotech and the recovery really
remarkable. One is that we've seen a string of commercial failures.
So we've gotten drugs approved, but they haven't delivered on their promise.
And what that's meant is that investors are now asking for a clear-eyed and
defensible quantification of treatment-addressable markets prior to
investing. If they don't see a path to return on investment, they're not going to
invest. And we know it's sort of a fool me once,
shame on you; fool me twice, shame on me kind of a thing,
that at the end of the day, the way that you make a return on investment is to have
a drug that's going to be commercially successful.
The second thing that's happened over the past five years is after
a period of time where oncology represented nearly 70% of all
biopharmaceutical investment, we recognized that there are other things that we can
do with biotechnology and make a lot of money.
So we've seen this host of new opportunities with far larger treatment-addressable
markets, with far less competition, less risk, and much, much
shorter timelines to approval. And what this has done is it's siphoned
investment capital away from rare diseases, away from rare cancers,
and focused it on things where their people are willing to not
only reimburse through insurance, but frankly, people are
willing to pay out of pocket, and this includes GLP-1s
and all of the other weight loss drugs.
And of course, we're seeing ADCs, T-cell engagers, not just for oncology,
but for autoimmune diseases. And any of you who've watched a sports game
recently, like my daughter can sing the Skyrizi jingle, and I'm sure most
of your kids can as well. That is where a lot of that investment capital is
flowing. And then finally, we've discovered that there is no such thing as
infinite price elasticity. There is a hard cap on price
on reimbursement, even for rare pediatric cancers.
And so as the populations get smaller, the reflexive thing to do is to charge more
because of the impact that you're going to have, but that does have a hard ceiling.
And so to show quantitatively, we have seen an increase in
biotech venture capital funding
increase over the past five years, $17 billion to over $21 billion
between 2020 and 2024, but that has not been distributed
equally. We've seen a threefold increase in funding for companies focused on
metabolism, and that's driven primarily by GLP-1s, a nearly
doubling of funding for companies focused on immunology, and again,
IL-23 and all the other novel autoimmune drugs, CAR
T-cells for autoimmune diseases and the like, and a 15%
decrease in funding for companies focused on oncology.
And that is a substantial decrease, and that is going to trickle
through the ecosystem.
So when we think about why it's hard to get new drugs approved for pediatric
indications with that as sort of a landscape, I want to break things into three
different categories because, again, I think we tend to think about this as a
monolithic
problem, and it's not.
There are, as I see, really three categories of how we get
new drugs to children. One
is to work with drugs that are in active clinical development.
And of course, the problem that we face is this very slow pace of initiating
pediatric trials for drugs that are currently in active development for adult
indications where there are ways to use that drug for a pediatric
indication. And I'll talk briefly about some of what I see as insufficient
financial and regulatory incentives, both on the positive and negative
side. The second place where we tend to get frustrated is that we
see drugs that we think could be really important for pediatric
patients or where we've actually generated evidence of activity for pediatric
patients, and then those drugs are deprioritized for their adult indications or the
programs are terminated, and that leaves us feeling super frustrated because
we know that there's a drug that we think could be useful, but we have no way of
rescuing it. And I want to talk a little bit about the complexity of actually
finding that diamond in the rough that ticks all of the boxes, that's investable,
approvable, and with sufficient patent life.
And then finally, I'll take just a very brief period of time and talk about some of
the specific barriers to making drugs that are specific for childhood cancer.
That is where there's no application for adult indications, and that really has
to do with the continued high cost and high risk of drug development for small
populations where new target validation and trial execution remains a challenge.
So let's talk about trying to move drugs that are currently in development for
adults. Why are the incentives not working?
And I would argue if you walk away with anything, it's that the carrots and the
sticks are simply not big enough. It's not that
we need more sticks, we just need bigger sticks.
And it's not that we need more carrots, we just need some bigger carrots.
The ones that we have actually work,
but they don't work well enough.Obviously, everybody's aware
of the drama around the approval or not approval, or renewal
or non-renewal of the priority review voucher legislation.
It has been finally, after a gap, renewed, and
those priority review vouchers as the scarcity of them
became concerning, the price started to go up.
And they are still valuable. They can represent $100 million or $150 or
$200 million. And to a small company, that's a lot of money.
But we are not able to factor that into our modeling for starting companies who are
investing in pediatric research because the program is still not
permanently authorized. It turns out, and I didn't realize this
until I was preparing for this talk, that the FDA has specifically now asked
that the program be permanently reauthorized, which is really unusual because they
weren't a big fan of the program when it initially came out because it made
everything a priority,
but they are asking for it to be reauthorized.
And I think that if we can have that step there, that will be helpful.
But it's important to remember for large companies that are developing a
drug for an adult indication, PRVs are only awarded if the
initial approval is for a pediatric indication.
They're not awarded for supplemental approval, so you can come in first for ovarian
cancer. If your next approval is for rhabdomyosarcoma, you do not get the PRV.
So it's a carrot for small companies who may be able to make that trade-off, or for
small companies who are developing pediatric-only drugs, but not for large
companies where the adult market is really the priority.
And as for the sticks, and by this I mean the pediatric study plans and the Race
for Children Act and the
pediatric investigation plans, they have had an impact.
They have done what they set out to do, increase the number of trial
starts for pediatric trials using adult cancer
drugs. That is an intended consequence of that particular stick.
But as you know, sticks have unintended consequences, and
one is the fact that we have in industry a
problem with lots of companies prosecuting the
exact same target. And what you see in the graph on the left is over
time, for any given target, the number of
assets in development for oncology and non-oncology indications.
And on the right, a breakdown of this.
This is a little bit old, but I think it's illustrative that in
2000, we had a large number of targets that we were making
drugs for, and we had small numbers of companies going after them.
And that's great to have that kind of redundancy because molecules fail and
programs fail. But on the right, you can see that once we had
targets that were well-validated, we had a huge number of companies crowding a
large number of products into that space, 60
CD19 drugs in development. Well, that's
great for adult DLBCL, but the problem is, if you've
got 60 CD19-directed drugs and
you only have a couple of hundred patients or three, four,
500 patients with CD19 positive disease who aren't cured by their initial
therapy, how are we going to do all of those trials?
And in the absence of prioritization or global strategy, we face a real
challenge. How do we find the best new therapies to take
into a limited number of patients with a fixed and diminishing pool of
resources?
So turning to repurposing, people might say, "Well, all right, understand
that. What about all the drugs on the shelf?
Shouldn't we be able to take things that are essentially worth nothing and
create value with them?" So there is a big quote
shelf, although I will disvalue the notion that there's an actual shelf with
deprioritized drugs on them. God knows I spent eight years at Day One looking for
them. There is no shelf. But what you do have is a large number of companies
that are now trading below their enterprise value.
And what that means is that for these public companies, the stock
market values them as being worth less than the amount of cash that
they have, plus the value of the internal programs, and that makes it very hard for
these companies to raise. And when they can't raise money, they ultimately go out
of business and strand their programs.
So you can buy these programs for very little money.
The problem is that the return on that investment is a math problem, and
that math problem is called the treatment addressable market or TAM math problem.
So if you look at this pie chart on the right, you see
essentially the breakdown of all childhood cancers by percentage.
Now, if you just stay with the United States, and we know that there's about
16,000 new cancer diagnoses per year, all you need to do is
multiply the smaller wedges in the pie chart here by
16,000. And if you take into account the fact
that we probably cure about 50% of patients with standard of care,
what that means is for anything that's not acute lymphoblastic leukemia or
low-grade glioma, the treatment addressable market, that is the
patients who you could actually have eligible for
treatment with a new drug, falls far below the level sufficient to support
biopharmaceutical investment.
And that is
really a function of something called net present value that
measures the present value of expected future cash flows with the present
value of anticipated cash outflows.
And what this means is that you're going to spend more money developing the drug
than you will ever possibly make, and that is a very hard thing for
any investor with a fiduciary obligation to their limited partners to
do.
And again, back to Sutro O2, I think that this provides a very important
lesson. The biology around the CBF-GLIS
fusion driving folate receptor
1 expression on AML was remarkable biology, and I thought it was
brilliant to apply a folate receptor ADC, and clearly, we
saw evidence of anti-tumor activity.
But the problem is that at the end of the day, this drug
was going to be a bridge to transplant.
And no matter how you slice it and dice it, with a small number of patients getting
this drug for four or five months or six months tops,
there's no way that you can make the math work.
There's no way that the
commercialization
potential of this drug was ever going to pay for even the cost of the
registrational trial, let alone manufacturing the drug in perpetuity for these
patients. And so we need to find different ways of
financing drugs for which we cannot commercialize them in a
traditional model.And you don't have to just take my word for it.
I'm just a baby VC. Here's a much older VC, and he will tell you
the same thing that I'm telling you, which is that investors invest in programs and
not just ideas, and that regardless of whether or not you're asking them for a half
million dollars, five million dollars or $50 million, those investors are looking
for a three to five-fold return on their investment.
And that is just unfortunately a hardcore fact of venture math that we
need to think about when we think about how we're going to pick the programs that
we want to invest in for pediatric cancer patients.
And then finally, with regard to trying to make molecules bespoke to
pediatric cancers, I think it's important to remind people of the current metrics
in terms of how well we do when we take a new molecule into the clinic.
And again, from this remarkable report from the IQVIA
Institute, they track the success or
failure rates, depending on which side of the glass you're looking at for drugs
that enter clinical development from phase one through to approval.
And you can see that while we get 50% of drugs,
and this is in the contemporary era, enter phase one and successfully transit phase
one to phase two, that rate falls to about a third for
phase two, going to phase three and about 60% going from
phase three to approval. And most drugs that get to approval manage to get
approved. But the problem is that when you multiply all these proportions together,
you come up with a composite success rate of about 7% to
9%. And that actually gets a further haircut when you
go and subset this by the mechanism of action.
And it turns out that we're getting worse, believe it or not, at making
small molecules get all the way through to approval, much better at
biologics as well as RNA and oligonucleotide therapies.
And so when you take the treatment addressable math problem and you multiply it
by the low probability of success, it makes it even more difficult to justify
making bespoke drugs for pediatric patients.
And this valley of death that I'm sure you've all heard about really
represents,
I think, in a snapshot, what we need to do to try to fix this.
We get very excited when we come up with a new target.
We might get very excited when we have a new molecule that we think has potential
for pediatric cancer patients, but it is a long and
expensive path until you get to that value inflection point where you
show the potential for commercialization, which is really the reward that
investors are going to get from taking a chance with their investment dollars.
And even if you do manage to get a drug to clinical trials,
and this is really the case with SUTRO-002, that's not the end of
the trek. It's really just the warm-up track for the next
part of the journey. Because getting to IND or to proof of concept or even to
approval is just the beginning of a long and expensive process for
whoever is going to make that drug into a new
medicine. And that includes things like enduring manufacturing,
securing supply chain elements, making sure that you have ongoing pharmacovigilance
and safety reporting, all of which is required by FDA rules,
physician and patient support, and I can't underestimate the importance
of medical affairs. Drugs don't sell themselves, and they also
don't teach physicians how they should be properly used.
And invariably, there are going to be additional studies required by regulatory
authorities. In general, whoever takes on a
drug program has to have the capital required to provide enduring access to
patients. Any new medicine has to at least pay for its own existence,
even if they're inexpensive to create or in license.
And I think a lot of people don't recognize that the back end
costs of medicines are really significant.
And this is my experience with toverapnib or OJEMDA now.
The FIREFLY-1 trial that we use as a basis for getting the drug approved, we
were able to get that trial up and running and well underway in about
two years, and we did it with fewer than 50 full-time employees and probably about
$100 million or so all in.
But the backside of this, which is getting the drug through to approval, running
a large 400 patient randomized frontline trial, building out a company,
medical affairs, commercialization, commercial manufacturing, regulatory, all of
that took over 150 full-time employees and over $300 million and
counting because that FIREFLY-2 trial is still ongoing, and most people
don't see that that investment is really where
these programs get so expensive.
So how can we adjust this? We need to find ways of moving
value inflection points in sooner, generating signals earlier, making sure
that the things that we invest in are real, and making all of it
cheaper. And the problem, the interesting paradox is that as discovery gets less
expensive, we're going to have more things that we can put into this
pipeline, but the middle parts are still going to be very expensive.
We don't have a good way of compressing those costs.
So I want to sort of finish with just some opinions, and it's a sort of chair's
prerogative that I have the soapbox and I'm going to stand on it right now, that we
really do need to think a little bit about prioritization.
And I love this, quote from David Packard of Hewlett Packard, which is that,
"More organizations die of indigestion than starvation." And I
think that's really true. I think pediatric oncologists have always been
afraid of starving for lack of new assets.
And the problem is, we have a glut of new assets, but we don't know
how to prioritize them as we try to eat as many of them as we can.
And the problem is, we have a fixed number of dollars and a fixed number of
patients, and we are going to potentially die of indigestion here.
So we need to really manage this fixed
number of patients and diminishing pool of resources more effectively.
We have to work together to focus on selecting the very highest
quality programs that have the highest probability of becoming new
medicines. We talk about in biotech failing fast or
failing cheap, and I think that that does need to be reconciled with the
traditional academic model, which is to dig all the way down to the bottom of the
problem and not abandon problems halfway through.
But sometimes when you're dealing with limited resources, you actually have to
think about that.
So how do we ultimately reach the promised land?
I really think that it's essential that we begin talking about really a global
strategyfor pediatric medicines development.
And I love this quote from Sun Tzu, which is, "Strategy without tactics is the
slowest route to victory, and tactics without strategy is the noise
before defeat." And I think we do really well on tactics.
But what that means is we run a lot of trials and we generate a lot of data, but we
still don't know how to get
those data turned into medicines for
patients. And we need to have strategy to organize our
tactics and really help guide us to getting things
across the goal line, CAR T cells potentially being
accepted. We have to understand what the goal really is.
Getting something to proof of concept but not having a path to getting it to
patients will have the exact same impact as not even getting it to proof of
concept.
And sometimes that means waiting.
It means having a target product profile for the disease, but then
waiting for the right drug to come along.
The age of therapeutic innovation is not over, and I think
my sort of plea to
pediatric oncologists is to not be afraid that you're going to run out of drugs to
try. You're not going to run out of new things to try, but maybe wait
for the right thing to come along.
And some final thoughts on how to get to our shared goal, I think that working as a
unified community and treating pediatric cancer drug development as a global
enterprise is essential. We should be running the trials that we should,
not the trials that we can, and we need to be ruthlessly efficient here.
I would also encourage us to consider how the industry is adapting.
There's a huge move to ex-US trials, including China, as a way
to not just reduce the cost of development, but to allow us to de-risk programs
more quickly and efficiently. And that only comes from working together as a global
coordinated effort. And then finally, and I will say this until
I reach the end of my days, we have to make sure that every single
patient's data is captured for real world evidence generation.
It's a travesty that we don't have a unified system to do that.
We're only hurting ourselves. We will make our lives so much
easier if we have high quality real world evidence that will allow us to
run single arm trials more efficiently for the purpose of regulatory approval.
And with that, I will pause and thank you for your time, and we'll take questions
for the entire panel.
Dr. Chaneway.
Again.
We should have put you up here, Dr. Chaneway.
No, no, no. I prefer being over here on this topic.
It's the easier side of the
room.
For the picture that you show, like the valley of death, kind
of, and you emerge on the other side.
I think one of the challenges that we always face in pediatrics is we're
interacting with, most often now, biotech, on one of
those two sides, like as they're sort of beginning and the
hope is high, or as we're sort of speeding towards
regulatory approval. And both of those have challenges.
It's hard to engage in that middle point when they're sort of
waiting to see. Do you have thoughts about that, like when the optimal
time is to engage?
My personal feeling is that the sooner that you
can
begin that conversation, and you may not always like the answer that you get,
because small companies very early
were rushing to the next value inflection point, be that declaring a
development candidate or getting to an IND or getting to proof of concept.
But finding a champion within a company and repeatedly reminding
them there's an opportunity here, or maybe even, and
I've tried this myself, which is calling companies
that have interesting and emerging technologies.
When we saw early RNA therapeutics coming out,
my thought was, "Holy cow, if I could knock down EBRS fly one
RNA, that would be brilliant for Ewing sarcoma.
Let's start talking to them about this as a potential means to proof of concept
for that new technology." And I got a remarkable number of people willing to pick
up the phone to engage on that. And I do think that
there is something to be said for putting in the time and effort
to remind companies that there may be advantages to
considering adolescent young adult trials or
pediatric trials sooner as a way of creating value.
You have to sort of speak their language.
Fortunately, because of the
challenging state of reimbursement for pediatric oncologists, there are a lot of us
in the industry,
and there are a lot of champions inside of industry for pediatric
oncology. Finding them, connecting with them, and reminding them of the unmet need,
I think is something that we should do more frequently.
I would agree.
Dr. Smith.
Yeah. Great presentation, Sam. Really learned a lot from it.
I think I'll just
make a couple comments on your last couple of slides.
And I think pediatric
oncologists know how to take a good drug
and develop it. In the examples that were given, if you give us
lenalidomab, we can do the trial and
really make an impact for the children with that disease.
I think the problem that I see now is
we got lenalidomab, but for rhabdomyosarcoma
or osteosarcoma and some of the ADCs that we
just really believe are probably going to be quite active, we
can't get them. And so,
I think, I hope, when we finally do get them and we
test them and we move them to frontline, we'll see something like we did
with lenalidomab in the 1731 study.
But that to me is just still so slow, getting the
high priority agents, in this case, some of the ADCs, into the
kind of testing that would move them quickly into the frontline
testing and make that progress.
Yeah. Again, I
wish I had a solution, but I can absolutely empathize with the problem, having been
on both sides. There's, within small companies, and
again, for new and emerging molecules, a lot of them are coming from small
companies. There's a finite number of hours in the day and a finite
number of hours or finite number of people who can sort of think through all these
problems. Unless you happen to employ Mark Kirin, who has an infinite
number of hours and an infinite amount of energy during the day to work through
problems. So, my recommendation is call Mark and he'll find a way for you to
solve it. But I would agree with you. It's hard to do.
The good thing is there are a lot more opportunities
for any one ADC that you see,
there are going to be a lot more in development outside of the United States, and
it's shocking
to see
the rapid proliferation of programs for validated targets in China and how
that is really about to be a wave that overwhelms us.
But it's also an opportunity because it means that there are
conversations to be had and potentially, I hate to say deals to be done,
but avenues that can be opened for trying to get access to
those molecules earlier. You have more people who...
A higher probability of finding somebody with a sympathetic ear.
I think what's important is how do you get visibility and how do you initiate those
conversations? And again, I'd refer you to the previous comment, which is leverage
the pediatric oncologists who are within industry or within investment banking
or venture capital.
Come to us and say, "I need this," because invariably,
someone like me or Mark is going to pick up the phone and say, "All right, how can
we help?"
Okay. Yeah. Well, I hope we get some of these, because
rhabdo, osteosarcoma, all of those, we really need active new
agents right now.
Sam, I would just add that,
again, in academia, someone who was there for 25 years
and didn't do enough in this,
we design academic trials for academics,
and we don't think about how the
end result is going to impact kids, rather
than just in our own institution. We've got some drugs.
We're treating kids on our drugs. We're going to get a paper out of it.
We get some grants, and we certainly get promoted.
If we're not thinking about what's required for approval from the beginning, and
again, I would still say that while we talked about some examples where maybe
approval isn't needed in every circumstance, I still think it ought to be the goal.
Approval doesn't just provide the kind of larger oversight.
It means that, for example, people that don't--
Getting insurance to pay for stuff is not always easy, and I think it's getting
harder in the United States, and approval is one of those things that ensures it.
NCCN guidelines in and of themselves don't do that.
And then if you think about the impact that has on the rest of the world, we,
as the academic community, need to really be thinking about
this concept of fit for filing so that the trials we run
are smarter but actually directed for what I think is
the outcome we all want.
Yeah, I completely agree. I think this, again, we have all of the
pieces. We have
pediatric oncologists with expertise in getting drugs approved, and we've got
pediatric oncologists with expertise in helping us figure out what drugs need to be
approved. And I think that the more that we can find ways to work
together with the goal, we need to agree that
if the goal is medicines development, then the goal is medicines development.
If the goal is publishing papers, then just let's say that the goal is publishing
papers. But I'm hoping that the goal is medicines development and that we
can leverage each other's skills and talents and perspective to really
focus our efforts in a really streamlined, strategic way to achieve that
goal. And I think the other pieces that we need, publications and
grants and funding and so on and so forth, will come.
Maybe with that as the final word, I want to thank my colleagues up here
for their participation and their great talks.
I want to thank you for your time and attention and great questions today.
Thank you very much.